here when every uploaders say hi guys
welcome back to little misfortune this
is where we got to after the demo so
this we played everything made the same
choices I can't over took the coloring
book last time but I did take the
coloring book this time and what else we
have The Rock The Rock the sabor rock
that dad threw us so yeah I'm really
excited to play this game I love Killman
D games I love Franco and I'm pretty
sure this kind of it
inter links with the universe from Fran
bow so let's just chuck some sprinkles
on this bird so I think this is like how
she sees the world when she puts the
sprinkles on things come on Miss Fortune
let's go ICP bird that's not a sleepy
bird misfortune
yeah
we want to carry on playing please I
used a little sparkle back there
yeah sorry anyway where are we
oh I can play look you party hat now
focus miss what you you have to make a
very difficult choice regarding this
puppy now be aware of the consequences
Oh play with it or sad it free play with
it then let's play ready I will play
with it so we come share a nice time
together
good choice now throw the ball at it
they Spall's thanks narrator
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with you sometimes
life is just unfair no I yeah well sadly
the puppy will miss the party are you
I'm so sorry no no this dog George is
having a party I think you have to go
and tell him about the accident yeah
let's go it's just a bit farther ahead
oh man sorry
I'm sorry I broke your poppy I really am
yummy to complain later you know with an
unbroken - oh God
she wear this sari a symbol of our
friendship guys our company our
companies we just killed the puppy like
bike I actually feel really bad no
mushroom are throwbacks oh ok so I
wonder what would have happened if I set
him free them because then his owner
would have been sad I just put know even
the glare oh it's you eat your grandpa
that's not the bad I think and watch
this anymore please let's keep moving
it sorry technical difficulties let's go
she's holding her stomach because she
feels a bit sticky that's why you
Oh what's this now that sign doesn't
work do you see all the crap lying
around that's a good observation
misfortune you mean thank you
it's not the sign doesn't work the other
side of this lake you will be one step
closer to the prize of eternal happiness
yes but it's not real thing lies he's
lying to you these crows of bloody
massive yeah if you haven't paid Fran
bro before you probably don't realize
this is gonna get ready dark I think
you're in big trouble miss fortunately
[Music]
she looks so Sofia loving about it fast
Oh kick him in the balls stick them in
the balls
alright
what it works where's she gonna Lambo
dress is good for one thing I suppose
this is thinking a long time even asleep
we didn't even go that high up well
time seems to slow down when we are in
danger we use anger what look why is
that bad
flipping us off this what a weird bird
okay
wait didn't I break my leg Simba you
seem very good at falling
thank you
so mr. Boies is the party on the same
line to the eternal happiness yes yes it
is
let's go lenient have you thought about
how to break the news to George ah yes I
mean oh wait no that's Benjamin oh wait
wait
boy you tell George about the puppy yeah
I'll have to I have to tell George
that's the least I can do for the sweet
puppy that is very brave of you
misfortune
[Music]
however you just a little bit farther
away yeah if you haven't played Rambo
you can watch me play from foe played a
couple of years ago now that what should
we do about it release it
we're not taking it with us it'll die oh
no I wanted to save it save the fish
although there are dead fish in there
and I didn't think of this it's gonna
die oh oh maybe we could have found like
a container with water and put the fish
in there
I'm not crying all of my decisions wait
games give meat sittings did you not
watch me play mound of madam kill
everybody I don't want to play that game
anymore okay lucky killing people and
yeah we are the house of George nervous
about introducing myself I'd love to
live by this again run it but it's brave
telling the truth about the puppy stupid
I'm doing it for the puppy your mom yeah
I'm doing it for the Bobby
there's a dead fish in George's house
this is not a good omen
we're gonna go in anyways
well let's ring the bells what the bells
are there for might not work though they
didn't work so we waited for half a
second you did not even wait I don't
want to go oh okay
dead fish I saw a man was floating in
the lake girls like this fishing
to an a hug oh this is cute
huh when I nice picture I wish I had a
picture like this with my mummy
he's wearing a Deadpool's uh t-shirt Lee
Haney oh I wish I had a picture like
this with my mummy Bobby hello
what is it it's fortune are you sure
this is the right house
what is the border hello excuse me are
you George
that's so dark I can't easily bring
really bad news
oh no wait it looks like he hung himself
himself like a pinata
should I hit him like a pinata no no
he's dead
he doesn't have any sweets and here's
where we never stood he can't be there
I mean Footwear does not mean misfortune
fear or live on earth this party's over
let's see yeah let's go meet you in the
back George you'll know now that you're
dead your puppy is gone I like the puppy
bye
[Music]
Oh God
how can it be so cute yes I'm sure we
can move it I don't go to you wouldn't I
love it eternal happiness yeah most of
all he just hanging around you song it
around
ah I love you too the trees and the
birds and the animals dangerous animals
misfortune you might run into a fox
Benja me yes but all foxes are evil so
keep your eyes open er all right
Benjamin how evil he's cute he listens
to rad music he says running with the
son of a child
alright
a janitor and I think jangles were in
France though I don't man hey what do
you have there
there is busy me wild dangerous Fox
marries that black tail it's Benjamin it
doesn't matter
attack it before he kills you no will
kill me he needs me BM to me is your
name Benjamin do you want to play with
me what really we are safe now
let's keep playing my game okay there's
a magical cave nearby you need to find
it okay okay take me two decades what's
gonna happen if I go in here wait it's
not the other part of what ever I just
picked up it looks like Benjamin likes -
oh no it's not that's pretty cool
focus misfortune we need do
not enough folks so okay
gifted it to you the little Institute to
do oh what's that police tape Oh God
you guys ready first to get to talk here
cuz it's bound to get darker the magic
okay it doesn't look bad magical no it
was already handy then go inside I don't
trust this guy what does this sign mean
oh I don't know sparkle oh sure whenever
you're ready oh let's just stay in the
forest is that actually enough shall
eternal happiness
I reckon Nicki that this is going to
touch the serious topics as well so yeah
just here does anything actually change
if I stay here
oh you're staying but then you won't
find the eternal happiness just go back
and see everything has changed
I love the way she runs
okay look
I can't adjust like that like when you
get given options and then nothing you
know it was like one is just totally not
valid but it's okay I said I still love
this games they love kill mind a game so
we go we go into cave thank you maybe
that was the quake inside make us feel
like we have a choice but actually we
don't just like life this game is huge
well let's explore the cave it was me
real comedian misfortune thank you I
really liked the dialogue I love the
communication and they brought her to
life they know how to prune character to
life I love that
what did I miss something I'm not sure
yes if a party magical hamster party I
don't know let's go find out
I think my read too big
who's up for seeing some hamster
knockers my husband are you going to do
something about it
oh no and the violence between the
hamsters
yeah like let's feed a helping hand but
I feel like that was probably the wrong
decision you have to give the recap no
don't make them kiss no no no no no no
okay a little bit bad something what did
they drop Oh God oh then I'm in a zone
II know you can keep nope Oh coach you
did
oh she's in school these animations are
so well done it's so good
[Music]
ah
yeah yeah oh she's still in the hamster
cave are you all right Miss Fortune she
handles it better than most people but
not that I would know these tiny cutie
course are dealing with a random one
let's go in then you believe this die
mr. Boies we have to find another way
out now okay bye
enjoy your pie oh hello look at them
with our tiny cocktails and their tiny
clubbing this is too cute for me hmm
smooching Oh trouble
oh no just gonna get to her little
Rimmer French the owner up the club back
that all free help you out she can
understand she can sir - yes you're
right
looks like you helped the criminal is
game oh of course it does safe with me
thank you
let's help you out here wait what's this
hello excuse me do you need a system Hey
Miss Fortune we need to find a way out
now the eternal happiness is still out
there
wait can we go back there now because
she's back can we get in into here
where did the way to the criminal go can
we get him now he is completely gone
fine it's probably that button it looks
like it's an elevator
here we go up we go good job miss
fortune you found the way out thank you
up we go
yeah we're going up nothing for us down
here we're too big for this world
these blokes just like a movie I saw on
TV these are the bad guys I'm telling
you these Gerald's we need to clear the
way before we can proceed Wow you see
that fire alarm over there we need to
activate it
yeah with a slingshot one string shot
this slingshot okay that's an easy way
to cover up plot holes just chuck an
array in their endeavour stuff that's
really clever misfortune
okay Oh
these are these like gerbils cuz they're
pretty big
oopsie Hey
oh wait the red lights up
oops yeah I had no idea what I was doing
I was actually aiming for the middle the
middle one with his gun we beat it
well done Miss Fortune hey hamster
gangsters wound face like Scarface oh
gee I do you guys ever got like an itchy
eyeball it's the weirdest sensation this
looks like the science project
fatty house in the basement I don't know
why but mommy was really angry about us
I can see why oh look let's watch it
let's take some more cash
no no what makes you think that is the
only thing that makes her happy
well your mommy is wrong I agree first
time I've agreed with you narrator mom
yeah let's go hey you on the other side
of the screen listen I know it must be
hard not knowing much about our little
lady's future will misfortune rarely die
if so how will she die and when will the
evil Fox kill her
where's your [ __ ] Benjamin I
personally Norma she's coming wait is
eternal happiness death don't tell us
that misfortune you made it
congratulations thank you don't listen
to him I will one step closer to the
grand prize of eternal happiness right
because I'm not allowed to be outside
this like you know don't worry it's not
far from here
great
who's that missing kid okay I keep my
out like this maybe I should go back
home I don't go now Miss Fortune I can
protect you leaving you to your dad hey
crow
okay you're on that way this week
I think the person in the car had no
yeah pupils wait wait wha
was that the missing kid oh hi
oh okay this is a is this a perception
on society and how we all walk around
with masks should I need to be happy
everyone honest fortune is coming to
open field that's all I wanna wear a fan
check it out later
who knows it's Halloween month two guys
do chemo let's vote my favor
I knew the eternal happiness first then
we'll see time check it out don't play
with my feelings now let's focus or
something don't engage with that wild
fox I told you foxes are dangerous hide
your child you are why I don't use rocks
let that wild beast run off I don't want
anything bad happening to you alright
so Benjamin's putting up these posters
saying hi as your children thank you
this is absolutely the best art I have
ever seen she says men she's no man
Jimmy was so creating creating that
looks like a child has drawn it she is
the child oh I didn't mean it like that
hey yes get the time focusing she
fancies boundaries
and we go into the park yes okay eternal
happiness Park makes sense
sport you language I got like that team
especially when I'm in the car and so
when it overtakes me on a one-way yes
fortune I got in the eternal happiness
yeah that sounds nice
you know I want to win this prize for my
mommy I wish I could give her some work
with her thank you anyway make me proud
[Music]
hey ba-bam great to be back I'm so happy
to be back streaming it's been way too
okay I agree with that sentiment not
because I don't like Brides because they
need to fend for themselves a lot of
sleep everything on the bench there it's
a life and it's eating from you sang
interesting what do you think a
misfortune do you really need to read
those poems
[Music]
yeah why not perms good yeah listen to
this one
both hanging - like that common
misfortune let's go alright
cute balls hanging today
who's that he used to sit on the thumb
box next to school he didn't have any
clothes on and they always officer beat
him with a stick you don't have any fish
to offer the seat out they love fish
yeah behind it
I understand misfortune I'm just saying
well
stop singing exactly misfortune good
thinking exactly the same thing as me
damn it I'm sorry
seagull but your name would you like to
ride my holes of the park actually you
tell about you do what you want but also
be careful please get help
yeah that's right this horse you know
[Music]
unfortunate are you alright because I'm
special little lady
of course you are really tiny and you
could break I broke my arm once so you
know what I mean should we try throwing
some sprinkles on on the seagull guys
anything sorry seagull nothing I can do
to help you
she count that back let's just go
it's fortune you don't want to get
involved with mine only does for real
would you like to show me it's not above
your dance moves
[Music]
no I want to dance that was unfortunate
what are you talking about that was
normal oh if you say so
my dad would you like to write this one
it's like a tornado yes all of the
rights please yes I want to ride I can't
no he's fought you that used to happen
to me wait am I just a kid I to this day
think I hold the record for the highest
Superman on the tire swing of my
childhood park because I literally put
my hands at the very top of the tire
swing and then my friend did a Superman
which means go around I'm really fast
and then I couldn't hold on anymore and
one hand went and another hand went and
then I just went flat and I had I got
winded but it was I was super high for a
while my legs went off so like wow when
the trees are naked when the wind is
cold when the smell of rotten apples
smash against the stone don't all of
these make like one big pearl or nothing
what are you talking about misfortune is
good tonight can I get up like
everything that I have is it time for
some things shake no chefs please one
tonight
escape
no continue know that happy happy man
wait wait wait let me sprinkle you
nothing this looks like the heart of
Benjamin don't you think I think it's
garbage and it should be raised with
fire
[Music]
just ignore it let's keep playing my
game
the prize is closer than you think
really
alright don't think somebody just stop
playing it I hope not I can almost feel
the happiness good the last challenge
awaits at the pet cemetery
I bet cemetery that sounds like the best
place to end the game exactly by
thoughts I'm glad you feel the same way
so I was thinking while we're walking
mind if I ask you a couple of questions
answering questions great
just answer as honestly as you can all
right first question have you ever
stolen anything
[Music]
I'm trying to think if I have ever
stolen anything
biggis
but I buried it in the yard
and never told him oh I'm so sorry for
the both of you
second question are you happy right now
[Music]
let's see what she says well many things
make me sad that's why I want the price
too much then I can stop pretending and
always happy Oh
the last question do you feel loved mom
these are such difficult question I
don't know you would she feel for me no
not in her environment that's why I like
my stony so much he's just a rock and
doesn't get angry or sad I wish I could
be like that sometimes thank you for
your honesty look we arrived at the pet
cemetery
oh there's another kid they keep lining
up look it's two Oh shake this out more
kids are missing if I go missing how
will I tell mommy you won't go missing
we'll go back home right after we find
the bride okay nice hmm
ready to find the prize of eternal
happiness yes what is it I have hidden
it in one of the graves I have to dig a
micron which one I'll give you a hint
it's where they inspired that goldfish
all right must I date with my timing
hands next or rather no use the shovel
what's wrong this shovel
okay can I look around this time he
didn't just chuck it out it see you she
just Chuck's at us he's one step then
these died surrounded by her loved ones
in the fire
[Music]
Oh No let's leave Deniz alone
okay let's see if this game is so messed
up I agree
the first pug to have a strangler man I
mean maybe that one because who cares
about this I mean this is the fish how
could a pug strangle a man I'm confused
Stefan the Queen writer of the erotica
novel confessions of a cat heretic novel
talk about crazy
this is obviously a cat so obviously it
says both i doing what if you love it
simple
yes yes forever is that a human
well what grade am I looking for again
was this is Louis let's say Roy GERD a
map I never saw that window coming huh I
don't get it I'm gonna read them all for
us and then choose I don't think so
I'll keep looking
it says mr. Popple hmm okay I think it's
this one
congratulations
just watch you you found the prize
really yes
you see the little box open it okay
eternal happiness is in stir-fries
there's only a new vendor more token
when you meet someone you think you know
I can they steal your eternal happiness
while I'm not releasable
[Music]
the Fox was trouble he stole your prize
we must find the Fox and get your
happiness back I'm sure he hasn't gone
far away let's go find him
Oh Benjamin did you steal my eternal
happiness
cool
give me back my happiness run after him
we can't let the Fox get away again he
stole your prize me let me do this
that's what she wants it to be what does
that do it looks like it gives us some
sort of powers but I don't think it
actually does when unloved children in
darkness search for what they have lost
for why they're in pain they have lost
for why they're in pain did you find
something
misfortune things
we should keep our eyes open in case we
see the Fox they know how to hide
Oh shake up this dong it's different
from regular stones I'm telling you I
think you're right
yeah I can see that what is this it's
business loose I'll take it for me maybe
it works somewhere else okay cool I have
a stone
oh no now show me the lighting nothing
at all well put it back yeah everybody
of death is what feeds the shadows off
the beyond huh does this mean that looks
like nonsense to means fortune ah really
maybe there's no more nonsense around
okay take this now cuz you've brought it
maybe there's some more stones we can
put it in some other ones
sorry crash that that hole looks very
much like where the Fox won't hide the
prize no reason why I'm with you there
yes don't worry nothing bad will happen
nothing bad at all okay you sound very
sure I'll trust you
maybe the hearts of work like sanity
points that's a cool idea since Tom I
guess maybe we'll find out if they
actually do something maybe it's just
like collectibles or something like that
like um in life is strange where you get
to do the graffiti and stuff or take the
pictures
but yeah hey Maria I wonder when Hong
Kong will steal my fries maybe he's not
happy himself sure maybe you guys can
share it but I need lots happiness
myself and for mommy yeah hello anybody
down there oh she is clumsy
oh I was a pretty big phone hello mister
voice are you there
sweet iPhone a little lemon haze back
well done that's us quite a feat oh no
isn't she fun deck
what about is it anyway around here nope
she is lost it
Vox repellent
Fox repellent I can't align the bottle
suite-style I'll take it
Oh
Oh
no one on Labradoodle cakes thank you
like what do you think we should do guys
I don't know like I kind of trust him
oddly I don't I don't already know
should we use the fox repellent or
should we just see what he's about to do
would you guys think I don't know do we
trust the narrator or do we trust
Benjamin shall we use the Fox repellent
or not see if you are now live in the
chat with me I am needing your input so
okay so
Yolo renascence says use it ever Luca
doesn't want me to use it though I'm
gonna have to just wait and see what the
majority vote is new casters no but not
stabby says now it looks like a lot of
people saying no zom says no as well as
a Milanovic all right guys I think this
vote has been cast and Maria Pizza
doesn't want me to use it either and and
now that is Jo pike so I'm not going to
use it
let's fingers crossed fingers crossed
Benjamin we are putting our trust in you
please don't curse
it's not what I that wasn't myself into
she's such a mess
maybe it was a mistake young man for
this I mean I saw her eating glitter who
does that it's not natural
misfortune you're alive like the
dangerous fox attacked you no I didn't
mean that I mean we did for sure though
see I told you that fox is evil no you
know maybe I shall listen to you we
still need to find a Fox and take back
the eternal happiness maybe we could
find out where he lives
yes give me a minute to figure this out
and I'll get back to you but then I'll
just hang around
hmm okay guys we we do not trust this
narrator don't want it to here yeah ah
okay but I think we can trust she keep
Yuki she's picked three times today I
think we can trust Benjamin and
hopefully hopefully he still trusts us
like maybe if we had to use the Fox
repellent then he wouldn't trust us and
there's a big error what I want to go
the other way now okay
anything on here local artists GM or
tires after in something look from you
my son is missing you
whoo the flute you know that's really
cute
I actually made a quick google search I
found out the Fox has a cousin in the
zoo ah well we could go and see if he
knows where the Fox lives but how do we
get to the zoo it's like really far away
why will you take the bus of course
there should be a bus stop nearby okay
no Alex black cat the Fox is not evil I
will I will not condone this
how did I get to the town center I
carried you here but how you're just a
voice in my head just a voice no I can
do more than that you know brother I
don't need to prove anything to you
whenever you say mr. Boies I mean he has
given you quite a few things already oh
she's not watching
that did you see no she was doing her
shoelace voice in your head misfortune
no what did you see I'm sorry I had a
shoelace problem ah that's just going
them
hi you look familiar mr. John
miss them
wait a minute is that yeah no you know
her know this Charles yes from school
she told our teacher to shove the
homework of his madness
she's very selenium oh she probably ran
away from home she will turn out soon
you think so yes okay
that's very true Maria pizza the Fox is
not the one who took the shovel from
hell that was the narrator
[Music]
and look at this very happy man looking
at his oh he's looking at alcohol of
course is those people in the picture
looks so happy drinking their youth yeah
juice juice is a wonderful thing
mommy brings me here all the time it's
really boring sometimes she sends me to
buy cigarettes while she hacks strangers
by the dumpster Oh God
[Music]
ooh a music store
that mouth just dropped his wanted scoop
down a wall I do Wow I'll tell them I
mumble that sir you drop your wallet
Lisa I'm not making us sell something
dude you know Lola
she already stole up pocket a switch
knife
he's gonna thank you no maybe no Oh
Watson what do we have yet for me yes I
love to write a good cool thank you
look is it the winner
what I do how do I do this
you man
maybe next time
[Music]
wait which way should we go should we
got him
when poor mommy took me here and forgot
me I got to play inside all night until
a security man found me he thought I was
the record well what sounds like it was
a small that's right for you yeah except
for me crying a lot but it was fun no I
want to I want to buy guitar
[Music]
it says let's place them sometimes we're
just too tired to smile you know this is
where we just where we buy I'm happy
okay yeah it's a creepy
I know it's door to is it Pacey's dad
who's Casey up front from school haven't
seen him for a while though
let's see the other missing kid
loads of them
look even more missing children posters
so nearly I wonder what they're missing
oh don't you worry about them I'm sure
they will all turn up one day you think
so okay
I don't know mr. voice this is starting
to smell mysterious
I agree bok is are these ones one of
these your kids
here we are
have you ever taken the bus all by
yourself before I'm not sure what to do
do we need a thicker let's find out
there's an information board
can you read Oh
their faces look terrifying terrifying
look this is quite cute though oh it's a
hearse sorry
I mean complete or miss Kelson up this
soon I'm gonna undo me behind and that
Benjamin should be ashamed that sounds
stop it says that all children under 15
years old can write the bus for free
that's you so I'm good great maybe you
lean above bacon you sound old
I'm definitely older but nobody can see
me here like 20 wait if you like the
kidnapper do as you please wait what's
this google shake this mouth that creep
is cold they comes Road okay gotta take
down the road who think miss fort you
Hey hello why did you take me to the
Skype with your friends so you know
because of you I can make you their
party oh okay okay just stay on here
then I guess I'm a bit tired from all
the walk in your mouth
I can't imagine you have very small feet
yeah a little and that's what I am
shake those old ladies out there a
little scary to New York honestly I've
seen worse
really yes you know my mommy also uses
the same milk she likes to hide her
smile and tears behind it you have a
mask like that
[Music]
yeah happy face free of regrets free of
self-doubt free of harm this bus trip
might take a while
are you okay with that he is keeping me
company
yes you know he's my friend from yapen
he's a ghost you know he's always saying
periodical sucka
you have really funny misfortune there
is no such thing as ghosts
Keeney mother good Asuka hey misfortune
look there's a bunch of cows on the
field
[Music]
[Music]
if you see that baby cow you think seems
to happen all the time I think we're
getting close to the zoo now okay great
well here we are
I can't wait to go inside you have to
tick it right let's see it Oh didn't I
give you a ticket earlier no you didn't
oh yeah I'm sorry I totally forgot
do you have any ideas on how to get
inside
you know without hey I could dress up as
a record I mean do the guy in the store
and she got some free food but I haven't
got any pizzas yes sir Oh
well I have 19 times you won't even when
you get older diversion hmm
what does that though there shall mean
well make the cashier look somewhere
else you know fool him not recipes are
working but I can do you already got
mistaking this one once stir it again
we knew about their missing children
here huh they knew about the many abuse
at that hello can I get inside what free
oh that's not gonna work
he just looks away from you Danny
tickets to the zoo
Oh yuck nothing that's only happened
oh good this is breakable like like with
a rope or something like I don't want to
win estoppel I think I came up with an
idea one what should we do you guys
should we break the window or tell a lie
I don't want to part with subtle but I
feel like we should I don't know what
what do you think oh I will allow you to
make this decision again see what you
say you said ladies let's do quite some
things yes she really has and yeah top
top top tactics this game is on steam
little misfortune might kill Monday
games they also have another game for
Fran bow both games very very good I
mean I've just tired to play this one
but it's very very good and I love kill
one day games that they're great you can
see their stuff on YouTube as well Maria
wants me to tell a lie what are the rest
of you guys think do you think I should
use my stone double Terra
why my lighter lie break the window I
think most of you want me to tell a lie
so let's but BAM wants me to tell the
truth I can't tell the truth there's
none option here I think I will lie you
guys tell me to lie all right doing it
how to my life so he believes it's a lie
Miss Fortune are you sure you want to do
this yes I mean that's the only way to
get inside
trust me all right let's go don't go to
the zoo I have to go to the zoo
come on the game's telling me remember
what what are you talking about
[Music]
can't go anywhere
hello excuse me there's one of them in
sunshine I got the bathtub I just saw
her you may want to go and check it out
yes either one
she is such a good liar
isn't this wonderful we all get to see
so many animals by the way you did a
great job not getting caught by the
vendor
very impressive don't but now we should
find out how well the walks and the
courage has gotten is the wolf
yes remember he knows whether Fox lives
okay so fine Benjamins 13 atlantis.oh
what do you just say to me give yourself
a [ __ ] won't you watch that mouth yeah
we need to get your happiness back as
soon as possible I love her sass it's
great lifespan 10 to 20 years lives
across the entire world they talk much
but say they're little they usually work
together with human tyrants no Fitz
founders of the liberation things mean
burning on them
why though his bird seems pretty smart
it isn't trust me on watching
just chilling meetings but it's all
delicious this normally him you know
libraries bookstores and coffee shops
the hipster our already smart they're
huge self-centered lifestyle dress them
together useless information they live
off the pension don't be
it doesn't know what a cool concept it's
a stupid I love it so much
multiple that's a very high rate with
different partners living behind
dysfunctional offspring they don't care
about anything as long as they are
occupied by mindless entertainment oh
wow
freakin love this game this is like a
big fu to so many things out that
great-great-great-great yeah sure why
not it's any bad seeds
boring light-skinned
we shouldn't feed the birds but whatever
so much does BM know find a wolf lariat
huh so we know whether there is I think
there's things about to close
[Music]
great job let's hurry up now
I'm feeling like alone what's happening
to me
I smell Homer wake not inside no comma
for those bodies preparing to create
life inside you you get a lot of new
feelings that are completely normal and
you'll bleed for three to five days from
your vagina okay narator stop you also
suffer each month for many years and
society
would you like god haha I'm gonna text
[Laughter]
[Music]
no it okay brutal honesty yes those are
people's wishes relations people
nowadays think they can buy everything
money anyway trickle to our coin and ask
for my happiness but also that Benjamin
transforming to a good luck sleep
because I will totally go out to my face
with him
Oh Q I'm just thinking about Benjamin
I wish I could write Japanese so I could
sell my cute postcard to my friend hater
my heroes ago just a ghostly stop lying
was watching ghosts are not real they're
just jealous because you don't have a
ghost friend
look at those sweet blushing they could
be all mine
don't get to attacks on those toys don't
worry
I'm yells look in can I go in here
this looks make their way to the wolf
yes let's go them
why is it something creepy like this
area is closed
oh we're not just being you will have to
sneak past the janitor to get through
the other side don't let her see you
otherwise you will lock you in all your
money like a swiveling Yahoo job
uncle hide behind those books that's
right great idea hide behind a box and
if she turns her back to you all right
ready let's do this
[ __ ] is fortune now wait for her to turn
it back to you thank you letter from
Mary watched know why I'm just doing
movies like all of them well this isn't
a movie so just do as I say when she
turns around you can jump out keep
moving
look there in the picture is sucking a
popsicle it looks like it's strawberry
flavored I just know the really comment
saying that I forgot to feed the birds
I'm gonna see if we can get back
oh I can't I didn't really notice that
maybe it's later on that I gets feedback
damn it I was supposed to move a certain
time oops oops
mustard Bible oh we should get out of
here and find the wolf all right is this
supposed to happen I think so I think so
okay guys I'm gonna leave it there son
needs fixing dinner and then I've got
break tomorrow but thank you so much for
watching the first part of liver
misfortune I'm definitely enjoying it
but lots do you let me know how you find
this and if you want to see it more in
the future I'll probably be streaming
anyway because I'm actually really
enjoying it and I think you guys are too
you seem to be really enjoying it so I
will let you know when I'm going to do
another stream if you want to be kept up
to date on when that will be
make sure that you follow me on twitter
my twitter is YAG main tanks I'm
basically AG my necks on everything but
also I do have a discord as well which I
will turn it in by
and a chat let me just get out scheduled
in by up
[Music]
okay
during the discard and we always chat on
this look like pretty much every day so
yeah if you just want to be kept
up-to-date on what I'm doing what's
happening on the channel when I'm gonna
stream next all that jazz make sure you
join the discord but I will let you know
on Twitter as well yeah I'm really
enjoying this it's extremely dark the
darkness comes out of nowhere which I
really like keeps you on your toes but
it's also extremely cute
oddly relatable kind of brings you back
to your nostalgic childhood but then
just turns the darkness to like a
thousand yeah I'm really enjoying it I
really hope you guys are too Congrats on
streams thanks Bob Ann and thank you Joe
pike for watching oh thank you for
turning on the notifications top tactics
if you everyone else hasn't turned on
notifications and you want to know when
I'm live-streaming again that's probably
a really good idea make sure you put the
notifications on and then your phone
will go buzz every time they upload a
video or that I go live so you'll be
less likely to miss it
oh and the discord is in the description
well it should be actually it's good
point it's in the description of every
video I'm not sure what the livestream
it's not in the livestream I will I will
put it in now
Hey
[Music]
join the discord they can I've updated
the discussion
thank you for pointing that out
yeah I'm really glad that you guys
managed to make it this tree stream we
really glad that I'm able to stream
again can't wait to play more of this
game and I hope you guys have a lovely
day or evening so I'm just gonna say
goodbye to the people that I can see
right now so goodbye hey Kaylee goodbye
it some analytic goodbye mantas oh no
you just got home
well thank you for popping in but then
why I'll be ready uploading this anyway
so you can watch this again
and I love the YouTube now has the
feature so you can see the chat like
live when you watch it back
I think that's that's really fun I
enjoyed doing that for other people's
videos but hopefully you can join again
Montez and I will let you know when the
next stream is so don't why this will be
reloaded and yeah bye info see ya bye
Nikki who else might be here
bye Maria Pizza by Bennet stavi by
Justin echoes by skintight our fragrance
by mr. 4p for in by Lucas by John Deere
by Casper by and andrey and Donald by
ninamu by gabriela pin and sleep goodbye
torrid and shocked I think that's
everyone and goodbye to anyone that I
might not afraid your name very sorry
and also goodbye to the lurkers goodbye
to the people who aren't in the chat but
I'm watching me elsewhere have I loved
today or evening and I will see you very
very soon
goodbye
[Music]